guys if you didn't know we are touring
america
oh america so you guys already know we
did like a quick little announcement
earlier in the month but we are here to
tell you guys right now that tickets are
officially on sale you guys can go get
them right now by going to
thetrashtastetour.com links in the
description here are all the places
we're going to oh my god i love that all
of these places there's so many we don't
even want to name them out just pause
and we'll find your city we're gonna
have a year's worth of trashing america
content just from this one tour there's
different tiers of tickets available so
if you want to make sure you are one of
the first people to get them and before
they sell out go now smash that link in
the description down below to get your
tickets before they all sell out because
i mean quite frankly i mean who isn't
going to want to come to us
i'm so important
so guys again head on over to the
trashtaster.com links in the description
below and uh for all of you americans we
will see you all there yes on with the
episode ready hi everyone welcome to
trash taste podcast including your
special guest me lilly pichu wow joined
[Music]
xenophobic xylophones welcome back to
another episode of the trash days vodka
that's your fault
that is your fault uh
yeah xena for all your xenophobic cell
phones out there shout out to you uh i'm
your host joey with the boys connor and
gone and uh she's already done it but we
have a little picture on the phone
she just took over our podcast yeah i
don't think that's ever happened this is
like lady beard i think where someone
just took over the intro
so yeah uh
disclaimer i just recently got gum
surgery so i'd like [ __ ] out on my teeth
if i like show it please don't be
freaked out okay okay
good good people in comments are like
what's that
gum on her teeth i'm like no it's just
uh i guess
we're jumping right into it lily's just
like dying to talk about anime yeah well
i used to have an anime podcast yeah
yeah that didn't last very long because
talking about anime only anime in a
podcast was like not
that's that's literally the problem that
we've covered why do you think we don't
do that yeah we started off as an anime
podcast although not really because we
had like one episode to do with anime
and then we just gave it like half an
hour it was like half an episode there's
only so many things you could talk about
it what's your favorite anime what are
you watching this season like what do
you think about that's just like what do
we talk about yeah yeah i mean that's i
think the biggest problem with every
anime creator uh which is you just run
out of anime to talk about because
there's only a few certain topics that
people really want to hear about
and then everyone just gets bored of you
like everyone's favorite anime is kind
of like the same thing you know most of
the time mine hasn't changed in like
well now i don't know okay arcane is not
an anime yes it is yes it is
it's totally an animator we love arcane
yeah jerry refuses to watch it wanna
he's a contrarian he won't watch
anything that's possible oh because it's
too popular
because people keep hyping it up and so
the expectations are just insane for me
now
it'll meet your experience
i've heard so many shows that with the
exact same thing and it hasn't they've
done the expectation so i'm scared now
i'm on team lilly with this one i think
it's all it's really good if it helps
you you can watch it in japanese dub
that's what they're used to
it's really cute like there's a part
where i called caitlyn cupcake yeah like
they did it in every single language
because it's a really hot scene sorry
yeah
and then he's
i've seen the japanese double that scene
it's it's better than the english dub it
is [ __ ] hot it is hot oh my god maybe
you would like that okay yeah maybe like
watch it in japanese i mean you can
pretend it's an enemy attend its anime
yeah even though even though conor
refuses to not call anything else
wait what you're like it's an anime yeah
it is an anime but maybe maybe we should
say it's not i just do that to knowing
people who are like
just fail you know yeah
did you see that yeah i didn't i'm so
excited are you excited i'm like kind of
scared wait it's is it three live-action
movies or three
the high expectations you have it'll hit
yeah i think i watched the first season
and i thought the first season was a
little slow but then i heard it gets
better and then i just
i i i never continued it after the first
season
but but arcane doesn't have that it's
just it's just win win win like it's
just great arcade for like episode one
[ __ ] incredible
joey wants to joey wants to die right
now
it's been zero days since volcanoes
mentioned
you really should watch it there's only
nine episodes out like what's your
excuse what do you want in the comments
section
great content great content
okay i will i will i love all this anime
talk arcane avatar such great nothing
but animals
okay question question since you're an
avatar fan
legend of core do you rate it i think if
they were told that they
could have more than one season because
i heard they were like they were meddled
a lot right yeah i think it could have
been so much better but i think there's
some good parts in coral like yeah i
like the first season yeah but then i
found the ending was kind of fresh
almost yeah it was kind of like okay
does it matter no no i mean i haven't
seen it but it doesn't really matter too
much before you watch something never no
why would you do that
you
do do that i remember now this is last
time i lost something you made it sound
like you do and then you said you're
like nah i'm getting like [ __ ]
vietnam flashbacks of the last time we
recorded an anime podcast together and
you said you read spoilers before you
watched the show
chinese not the destination i'm a firm
believer of like if i know what happens
it doesn't detract from my viewing
experience because either way i'm
watching it
but why not have the experience of like
say being able to watch it
but then you actually of not knowing
what's gonna happen yeah the anxiety
did you get anxiety reading the spoilers
as it's going on
sometimes but like when i read this one
oh that's how it ends oh that's how the
conflict is resolved i feel much better
let me enjoy and watch this now you know
but you already know what it's going to
be before you watch it
this has like divorced parent energy
like i just wish i could know when
they'd stop fighting
where will they like i just want to know
if i had a crystal ball that could
literally tell me anything i wanted to
know i would take it like i want to know
when i die
when my dog's gonna die like when like
what do you want to do what do you want
to know about i could treasure every day
before
you know what i'm going through
it's nice the information is nice you
know what would have happened if i like
went this route in my career or this or
whatever wouldn't you like
everything let's say if like life this
crystal ball told you that you were
going to fail you'd be like well why am
i trying then right then i just died
in that case if we just knew everything
that was going to happen because
everything's predetermined in that case
yeah but there's still like i can still
experience it right just because i know
like oh i'm going to drink a lot here
and have fun but i'm still going to
drink and have fun you know
so you don't like surprises is what i'm
hearing yeah i guess it's just like
knowing stuff it's anxiety i don't know
there was one time we went to watch a
scary movie yeah and i just i could not
take it i wanted to take out my phone
and read the spoilers
okay actually actually i was going to
say there is one case where i do just
read and watch spoilers
horror movies
because okay i'm a natural i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] when it comes to horror movies
i'll be honest like i hate not knowing
what's going to happen
but like but like at the same time i
think a lot of horror movie concepts are
just really [ __ ] interesting yeah so
i like i i watch more videos breaking
down horror movie spoilers than i
actually watch horror movies sydney's
gonna [ __ ] kill me because she
[ __ ] loves horror movies but i i i
think i've known like most horror movies
like the plot of most big horror movies
i think i get what you mean like i've
seen an arduous amount of like would you
be able to survive this sawtrap video
more than the actual song right like i
haven't seen a single saw movie but
goddamn i want to know how you'd escape
from because like horror movies have
some of the best hooks of like any films
like
you can born it down to like one tag
line or one like it's basically a
youtube clickbait you know it's got like
the interesting concept but like i don't
want to experience like the [ __ ] of
like getting scared and getting jump
scared right and all that [ __ ] oh that
reminds me of my other favorite anime um
you know movie recaps on youtube
yeah i i watch that so much like i don't
even watch movies anymore i watch movie
reviews you have the same brain as god
god does the exact same thing hello
there what's up recap here today i'm
going to tell you a story about blah
blah blah blah blah blah watch out and
take care
no i'm just i just like your accent
okay i was like is this like an accurate
yeah i've i've never related to someone
so hard because
i thought i was a psychopath really you
guys should try it it's good bedtime
stories you just put one on and then you
just like you you listen to someone
explain the movie plot yeah
you don't need to spend two hours
watching the movie no i i totally get
that with movies
i watch youtube videos at 1.5 speeds you
know you you don't need
i cannot do one speed
that's psychopathic
but like no i totally get that with like
movies that are say like really [ __ ]
up where it's like oh really [ __ ] for
example it's like yeah okay i'll watch a
guy breaking down a movie but if it's
like do you do that with all movies even
ones that you look at and you're like oh
that looks interesting no not all movies
yeah so most of like most movies are
like i think in like the let's say the
six to seven
out of ten range if it's a marvel movie
you're gonna watch it depends on the
marvel movies
but like sometimes i just i have certain
marvel movies that i want to watch and
experience the fullest but like i don't
want to watch all the [ __ ] that
comes before it like for example when i
watch when i'm going to watch doctor
strange i don't want to [ __ ] watch
one division i'll just watch someone's
summary of one division
is not a bad tv show is it awesome you
should watch it i think it's a little
weak but did you did you watch the new
doctor strange movie i did did you like
it um
okay so there were so many elements that
i really liked the horror elements were
fantastic but then there were some
really cheesy lines yeah yeah i didn't
like it there was some really cheesy
i've actually sported myself on the dr
strange movie because of this guy
actually
because i have like certain movies where
i'm like i want to experience this the
fullest i want to not spoil myself and
then some of them i'm just like eh
whatever i just i just want to know what
happens like
yeah like like when you say doctor
strange was like mid i was like okay
well
yeah yeah no more views is a perfect
example of like i'll just go and watch a
recap yeah because like i'm not gonna go
[ __ ] i'm not i'm not even even gonna
watch a [ __ ] recap
i only watched the recap so i could
understand the memes more i really
thought they said it's morbid time in
the movie yeah i thought so too they
don't say it i i i thought so as well
yeah i thought that was an actual line
that people were mean for for the
longest time i thought oh it's just a
line in the movie it's just that bad
yeah i really thought
i just loved the idea of just just
memeing these really terrible movies and
giving like the executives that's like
wow people love this movie everyone's
talking about if they don't say it's
morbid time and more views too i'll be
thoroughly just direct to tv right it's
direct to apple tv is it it's it's not
going in like it's not it's not a
cinematic release
at least well no i didn't get a
cinematic release sorry no the second
movie is not going to be a theatrical
there's going to be a second one yeah
yeah they're making a second one why
would they do that
was so popular
but like look at google trends
but like didn't they like who who
produced it against sony i think it was
only the producer didn't they like
re-release it because of the memes yeah
cinemas and then it [ __ ] bombed
they were like people want to see this
because it's everyone's talking about it
let's re-release it [ __ ] bombs like
so i'm surprised they're doing a second
one honestly i i don't know how it's
going to work
it's not that's the thing is the first
one didn't work how do you talk the
first one
oh my god so have you ever read like a
spoiler to like a tv show or a movie and
you've kind of like regretted it has
that ever happened never like literally
never i
just enjoy media
my gosh you guys accent reminds me of
harry potter i think harry potter he's
australian
i'm not even british
that's the most i just want to segue
into like i think harry potter should be
anatomy
ah yeah i mean
so what i mean what did you think this
did you watch little academia that's
basically harry potter yeah that's true
it's harry potter with little girls
that's all it is
i mean it's got the vibe down but it's
not exactly harry potter it's more
cutesy than harry potter obviously
obviously yeah obviously if we all
watched harry potter
they're not
yeah oh yeah we've ordered characters i
haven't watched all of them what do you
mean
i had i got up to a goblet of fire what
the [ __ ]
okay so i haven't watched harry so i've
seen half of it okay so i've watched up
to goblin or fire and then i skipped the
last movie
how did you even have your citizenship
what the hell i thought cause like to me
like i was never that obsessed with
harry potter i swear i've met more
americans that are like really into
harry potter than i have generation yeah
yeah yeah i like um you know how an
avatar it's like oh what element are you
harry potter what house are you like i
like things like that you know i like to
compartmentalize my friends into
categories in my brain
so we are just the british guys and i
guess element yeah an avatar like what
element [ __ ] i don't know harry potter
i'm a slytherin oh in harry potter i'm a
hufflepuff everyone's a hufflepuff
everyone how do you know what house you
are there's a official quiz you can do
oh is that yeah
how's everyone done
because everyone knows at least one over
[ __ ] enthusiastic harry
potter oh my gosh guys what mbti
i'll get into astrology next if you want
but wouldn't it be ti type you know i i
i don't know the code but i know the
name what is it executive uh assertive
or something i don't know i don't know
what am i because you made me do that
test i mean
hold on
i'm a i'm something with an eye i
remember
[Music]
yeah e-i-p-t i guess i don't know ptsd
dude you want to explain what this is
because i think a lot of our audience
might not know what oh i don't know [ __ ]
i just like asking this
it's like do you know yours
infp is that like the artsy one yeah i
think so because there's one like it was
a woman with like butterflies yeah and
i'm like oh
that might be my one as well that sounds
familiar yeah maybe i had an eye in my
mind mine was a woman who looked
stern so i don't know what that says
about me i'm funny you're stunned don't
explain what this is because i'm like
i'm sure a lot of our audience are lost
right now it's just like they're just
saying letters they're just saying
letters right now fun personalities it's
not anything serious yeah yeah
i think ash does all to do it though
it's like it's like 16 questions isn't
it no no personalities yeah it's it's
it's it's like astrology but for
psychology i think right yeah that's so
psychology
astrology
a fun for psychology
starter
it's a very rough way of kind of saying
i'm kind of like this this is what i
would say i focus
put my personality into it yeah i mean
it makes more sense than astrology
at least you know because yeah it has
like i guess logical steps to categorize
you but it doesn't always mean it's like
100 accurate i mean there's more than 16
personalities out there i'm sure
that's it that's the cap it's really
nice and neat we love yeah we love it
that it's 16.
it just doesn't make sense
i never do do you believe in like the
astrology stuff no no but it's funny
it's funny yeah it is i i think it's
more fun than some of my friends are
very into it i'm like oh you're a
scorpio yeah your scorpio with a scorpio
rising and your moon is taurus that
means like at this day they're like
super into it i feel like it's just an
excuse for like women to be racist
sometimes
it's like the highest form of classism
think about it whatever anyone actually
like talks about and i i i cannot be
near a scorpio you're like what's wrong
with you
i'm a leo oh yeah
see what i mean so you can judge me wow
energy coming from you right now yeah i
can't believe i i i don't know how it's
just like everyone born in july is just
this this [ __ ] weirdo who's like
has [ __ ] rulers and it's like
yeah right he does get a very angry but
do you know what you are yeah i'm a
gemini gemini yeah yeah oh yeah it makes
sense yeah can you glean any information
from that
you you you're uh you're a cancer i'm a
libra
that's a club
did i just hear that
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah because like for like the
for like about like 10 weeks straight we
just could not stop bringing up arcane
after it launched because it's so good
right because i've watched it yeah yeah
yeah yeah exactly and also we're like
league players kind of
yeah oh what wink are you guys
when i used to play i was diamonds no no
no no no like now
i haven't played in like two years yeah
i haven't played what are you bronze
so i would now know i am
i i feel really bad sometimes when
people watch arcane and they're like oh
wow i want to try leaving yeah yeah yeah
and they go into game and it's nothing
yeah yeah it's like everything about
arcane once meets like wants to get me
to play league again and like i play one
game and i reminded like why i stopped
playing league i mean the only thing
that's like accurate between the game
and the the show is that like there's
racism between like the characters and
stuff
that's like that's pretty accurate
it's a fantastic you don't even need to
know about me too
you know we played league on the eu
server and the eu server is uh that's
just awful oh yeah
is there a single good server no no but
like europe because obviously you shove
all the european countries on the wall
yeah and then everyone's like you know
everyone just bullies french people
immediately yeah what does it stand for
it's gamer subs gamer subs game of subs
yes oh wow that's cool i like the
so actually we kind of we kind of like
jumped ahead because like kind of like
jumped into it normally what happens
when we when we have a guest on is we
have the guests introduce themselves and
what they do
in case our audience doesn't know uh
what's uh but you are immediately like
what's your star
watch arcade watch you all cancer
[Laughter]
i'm on youtube i stream sometimes i
voice act i make music
i like anime
so like how would you categorize
yourself as a content creator now are
you just like a bit of everything now
yeah i like to dabble in a little bit of
everything but not excel in like one
thing you know
i mean you managed to stay online and i
best always get more and more popular
and relevant as you go yeah i think it's
uh
well i mean
i'm in a bit of a dip right now but you
know i mean you're doing well you've
been around me so long like you've been
on the internet and you've been in like
the content creation space for like so
[ __ ] long
so long wait how like when did you start
what year was it literally like i feel
like over 10 years ago like i was like
19 or something i mean like
well i i started um voicing
cartoons anime you did fandubs right
yeah
yeah i think
yeah yeah early youtube fan updates were
like
interesting yeah
because were you part of like the va
crowds back in the day when everyone was
like fan dubbing
yeah
i really did want a voice actor so i
never gave up on that dream yeah
thankfully got some roles oh yeah hell
yeah
thank you yeah
um
yeah that's how i started
sick it's such a long such a such a long
journey and uh so
like so how did you like transition from
just doing anime stuff and then you
started like streaming and then you got
into offline tv how did like that happen
oh my gosh like how did it happen like i
just started making videos people liked
them and i started making and then you
know once you get more cloud and viewers
you can connect with other people in the
industry yeah yeah yeah
um offline tv was like you know scarra
yes yes
and he's like no there's no way we can
get it it was really cute i think he was
really it was a
honestly a lot of why my career has um
not died yet is because like the
connections yeah it's really hard for
one person to do everything by
themselves yeah because like either way
you know popularity fades yeah right
like looks fade or whatever made you
popular face like things new trends come
if you can't see on top of it you're
gonna fall behind yeah so like
definitely being offline tv and like
connecting with other people collabing
helps a lot yeah yeah like i would like
to um like for example remember the when
the pandemic started remember the whole
among us craze yeah of course that [ __ ]
like made so many people's careers oh
yeah yeah yeah i remember like corpse
husband especially like
husband went from like i have never
heard of this person before he's like a
superstar now yeah to like to like k-pop
levels he went from reading creepypastas
to like selling multi-platinum yeah yeah
how the [ __ ] do you do that and michael
like likes to listen to creepypasta
before he goes to sleep he used to
listen to corpse husbands and now corpse
is like
like yeah
yeah
superstar yeah now especially in the
it's very volatile scary i mean it is
but i guess that's just part of like
the career that we've
chosen right it's it's scary you wake up
and you don't know if you're gonna have
a career next year like well one year is
like such a long [ __ ] time in youtube
space which is why i find it impressive
when anyone had can be around for like
as long as you for example i'm like a
dinosaur
you've been around for a while
anime back in the day you just like
recognize his voice because you were
like what were
we don't need that
he didn't even get his silver play
button no i didn't because i got it they
got the 100k i think before they started
sending off silver play buttons
so i just never got them yeah yeah
that's impressive i think i do think
anyone who's been on the space for like
that long you've got to be doing
something right like yeah you know what
can i like take you so far so yeah so
when i started doing youtube it was
because i was getting annoyed with voice
acting i was like i don't want to
[ __ ] keep fan dubbing other people's
stuff right i don't know if you were the
same kind of thing so we've all reached
that point yeah cause you're like i'm
just tired of everyone taking their time
yeah everyone's like they've taken so
long you audition for something they're
like you got the part and then they're
like they never do anything or they make
you record stuff and you don't do it is
it was that like a similar thing for you
or you were just like i'm tired of
waiting for those projects yeah yeah
eventually you get tired and you want to
like do your own thing yeah yeah the
same for me yeah so you talked about
offline tv before and how that started
see we were there right at the beginning
near the beginning yes are you allowed
to talk about what like how that formed
at all well back then it was like chris
who's no longer with us scarra pokey
you know who's no longer with us poke i
think they just wanted to make like a
content creator group yeah right and it
was like
they invited me to live with them right
that was like really weird at first
at that time i just broken up with my
boyfriend like a really bad place and
yeah
i live with them and they're like all
right wake up at 5am we're going boxing
and we're gonna make it into a video and
i'm like
what
it's just like
it started out as a group of friends who
just wanted to make cool videos yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then eventually that
like expanded to what it is now i think
even today we have trouble like
separating the friends from the business
because if you start off as friends but
you want to make it a business like a
full-time organization you're gonna hurt
some feelings right it's impossible yeah
everyone has i think that's why i've we
feel lucky that it's just the three of
us because i feel like when it gets like
a large group it's always hard to manage
everyone equally right
yeah yeah exactly
how was it like how is it living in a
house with like i guess your best
friends making content together does
that make it like harder to separate
friendship oh yeah for business it was
always intertwined we could not separate
it but it was fun because we would pop
into each other's streams whenever we
wanted it was easy to like collaborate
it was like it was nice yeah yeah but i
imagine always having to be like on
it's probably tiring sometimes but it's
also like you know we liked each other
so yeah
yeah
was it easy to like hang out as just
like a group of friends without feeling
like without feeling pressure to like
say make content about it or make
something out of it yeah okay that's
closer to a lot of people this episode
is sponsored by paypal honey the easy
way to save when shopping on your iphone
or computer gentlemen we're a bunch of
zoomers right yeah right at least we
like to think we are and we all shop
online but doesn't it suck when you're
at checkout and that promo code field is
just taunting you thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey's the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best
ones it finds to your car
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite websites when you're at the
checkout the honey button appears and
all you have to do is click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons that worked for
that site and if honey finds a working
coupon you'll watch as the prices drop
so guys we've been in america for about
two three weeks now what has honey saved
you money on well when i came here i was
missing a lot of stuff to do my stream
setup and i received a bunch of stuff on
different wires cables everything i
needed thanks to honey if you don't
already have honey you could be straight
out missing out on savings and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
favor and supporting us too so what are
you waiting for go to joinhoney.com
trash taste
trash taste back to the episode i did um
hentai voice acting with you right yeah
you did yeah that was fun i think you've
done a few things i feel like that's the
only thing i really did wait hold on do
you want to explain that so so i did
this video uh series where i used to
take like notoriously famous like bad
clips and i was like let's see if like
we
just fix only the voice acting will it
will it like prove that that's the thing
is that the one i did with you as well i
think you've done it yeah you did as
well because a lot of the time people
have this notion about like shows that
are bad voice acting and it's like it's
it's definitely the voice acting and
it's like well all right well let's get
good voice actors to do the exact same
script with the same music and all that
and prove that 99 of the times it's like
everything else and then of course if
you throw actors into a bad script or
terrible animation it's gonna it's not
the actor's fault yeah so i wanted to do
that and so i i got uh ready to fix some
hentai clips that was fun yeah i like
that he was like you want to voice me my
[ __ ] yeah let's go
that's fun
back when connor did voice acting uh
yeah
yeah
voice acting is fun try to try to like
think of how you can kind of expand it
and kind of make it into more content i
feel like at least right now i'm like
there's nothing that i can think of
that's like a great idea
i definitely got as much out of it as i
think i can for now i don't know also
that fixing voice acting series i could
tell
spent like you spent
that's a long time yeah yeah because
like i think the biggest thing is just
scheduling that many people yeah in like
that many time zones yes i remember when
i like used to do a bridge series like
it was fun up until i had to like
[ __ ] schedule recording sessions with
everyone which is just like the biggest
pain in the ass
and i i mean i would do all the voices
if i really felt comfortable but i'm
like i'm british and a lot of the times
i don't want to do an american voice
you're an american voice
on command i don't want to
i've done american and for
movies and stuff as well though okay
we're gonna do a scene okay no no
no no no set up the scene all right hi
welcome to starbucks how can i help you
um uh hi
[Music]
can i get
an americano please [ __ ]
is that all you're gonna get yeah yes oh
do you have a point system [ __ ] no [ __ ]
i have crippling anxiety
oh hi there my name is markiplier
you just give me a coffee
i kind of realize you just did a marker
whenever anyone is like do an american
voice on stream or some [ __ ] or because
i if you give me the line and you give
me like my time to go and read it and
and make sure it sounds american it's
totally fine but on the spot i'm just
like oh hey guys this markiplier here
like that i'm just like
what the [ __ ] yeah because you just have
that like familiar like sound and voice
right because like i'm the same when i
try to do an american accent i just turn
into like a [ __ ] socal surfer well
yeah so when when you have a british
accent right your tongue is kind of like
curled up like this yeah everyone's ever
know yeah so if you want to do it so
that if you want to be american same
with australia you just flatten your
tongue and push it back yeah but when i
do that i
naturally i sound like markiplier or
like somebody i think it's like the same
like subwoofer
in like your voice
do you want to make more voice acting
content is that where you feel like your
passion is um yeah i would love more
roles but sometimes you have weeks where
you audition and you get nothing bro the
auditioning is the hardest part it's
like soul-crushing
how many auditions do you like record in
a week and then how how hard you look as
you think because i'm not with like an
agency i freelance for an agency and
sometimes i get auditions from like uh
it's like christmas it's like oh my god
i'm gonna be happy for the next year
right oh my god
that's so rare you know i wish i could
get more but i know it's competitive a
lot of people do it it's really hard
even getting the auditions yeah it's
take a long time and for the as well i
mean obviously at least i'm sure you're
the same for me i don't give a [ __ ]
about like the money part of it of
course right voice actors usually do
this because they want to do it yeah
yeah cause anime jobs don't pay
wow it's it's the bragging right to say
i'm in that yeah because i think yeah
anime pays i think the least of any type
of voice
acting for money yeah yeah i mean i mean
that's just been true since the
beginning of the like the anime industry
it's it's it's been known that if you
want to get into the voice acting field
for anime it's a hobby job it's it's
like a passion job you know because
you're not going to be able to sustain
yourself
like you know commercials yeah yeah i
think original animation that's the
dream yeah um that'd be cool that would
be cool right imagine them animating
stuff to your voice instead of you
trying to fit your lip flops and then
reading like oh the stub is better
do you know uh the legends of the
galactic heroes
yes i know that anime yeah so i i did a
voice for one of the episodes recently
and oh my god the lip flaps in that show
were intense yeah yeah i actually did
another show before that and uh the guy
most of the time was just talking to
himself in his head and i was like this
is [ __ ] easy yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so i didn't have to match anything but
legends of galactic heroes is like
famous for being a very like political
talking anime
i didn't even have that many lines but i
was struggling so hard because they were
like so precise lip flaps and i was like
why would they do this because in
japanese they don't even [ __ ] match
them yeah i think that's the ironic
thing right yeah the dubbing the dubbing
process they care more about the lip
flaps than the japanese version jeffy's
like oh
yeah yeah it's so bizarre how like
japanese don't even give a [ __ ] about
trying to match them yeah it's it's like
what what
in english it's such a big deal if you
look closely there's like a bunch of
scenes where like the voice acting
starts before or after oh yeah yeah
no one cares that's interesting wow yeah
but that's not your star role though
because you voiced the monkey as well
right i did yeah yeah you weren't sure
the corpse thing did he give did he give
you that role as well
corpses like messaged me one day and he
was like is that the anime where you're
saying
yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
corpse it's it's like the danganronpa
from the same as the danganronpa
i saw i saw all my friends part i didn't
know you were at a monkey so yeah one of
the parts was like
yeah i
why are you looking at me like that when
you're saying it so yeah it cops are
like you want to be a monkey and i was
like that's sick that's [ __ ] yeah so i
went on call and they were like do you
have much voice acting experience i was
like yeah and they were like well don't
don't worry about it because it doesn't
matter anyway you're going to be a
monkey
could you demonstrate like what you do
yeah so they were like could you give me
a running monkey sound like
how do you not laugh that was the
problem they were like could you do
another one without laughing
because they would be like we want five
seconds of uninterrupted monkeys
all this
training monkey voice actor
let me know if you need a monkey guy you
watch it afterwards you're like that's
me
i did yeah yeah i was like i'm finally a
monkey in a show that's always been like
a dream are you the kind of person who
is completely okay hearing your own
voice when you voice act i think when i
it's like an anime or something i'm very
proud i'm like oh my god that's me
that's me yeah oh my god okay i voiced
um in miss nagatoro that was like the
biggest anime voicing right i was so
excited to show michael i'm like no it's
it's really cute and wholesome i swear
and then i showed him like an episode
the first episode it was
she goes hard that first episode like
what am i watching
dominate
in like the first episode she makes him
she makes like the main character
no but my character's yoshi she's really
cute all my stuff oh okay yeah yeah so
many scenes where i was just like she's
just bullying the [ __ ] out of this
and they're so mean and they're like
yeah like the first two episodes
especially like she does not hold back
at all she and there is a worrying
amount of people who are really into it
yeah i i thought it was like a slice of
life like comfy wholesome from the vibe
i got and i watched it i'm like oh i
mean it doesn't get wholesome it is
it's that initial hump of just like it's
pure like here's like a dummy mommy step
on me energy and then it gets wholesome
afterwards which it's just i didn't know
there could be a show that teeters on
slice of life and psychological horror
because for some people personally that
is an absolute [ __ ] nightmare
in real life that wouldn't that would
not fall she would be scary
no it's just a wholesome story about
these four girls i only saw like porn of
it though like people were just posting
that's because the original creator is
uh
yeah yeah yeah
twitter
yeah twitter twitter had a field day
everybody
profile pictures
yeah i know that's pretty much the point
of it huh no no i didn't seek it out i
was i was on to it i mean i followed
joey so you know i mean so it was just
on your feet it was just on my seat yeah
i would not i mean that's just like all
our feeds now at this point especially
if you follow joey as well but sometimes
some people in my following like
followers list they retweet literally
hentai yeah okay i don't retweet any of
it no i just like it okay it's i okay
and it just appears the problem is okay
there's some artists that i really
really like but they also support other
artists and like it's got it's gone so
extreme now that i've completely
forgotten how weird it is to be
scrolling in public on your twitter
timeline and [ __ ] hentai appears yeah
i'm so scared
i'm browsing but oh big big melons yeah
right there
i'll tell you what because like living
in japan everyone just like keeps
themselves no it's yeah it's normal like
when i went back to england on like a
tube and like there was just like on the
metro and like you see a lot of people
around you you feel so [ __ ] awkward
and it reminded me in england how
awkward this is and how not normal this
should be but because living in japan
it's just like it to me it's just become
normal now just to have like full-on
anime titties on my timeline maybe you
should just normalize it be proud of who
you are i mean i could
i mean one day one day we'll normalize
anime titties one day
i'm going to japan next month i'm very
excited about that oh yeah how would you
like are you able to get in on what visa
yes yes or tv trip oh awesome so it's a
business trip also yeah it's a business
trip oh yeah we're gonna hang out in
japan man
where are you where are you guys going
uh we are going when does this come out
i'm not sure actually i'm sure probably
by the time ax comes out early july yeah
yeah early july or something in july
okay
are you guys going to ex hell yeah yeah
i mean of course we are we are we're
we're
like i feel like every year ax it gets
more crowded yeah can't get it anywhere
there's just lines everywhere yeah
people everywhere
uh we're doing the 21 plus lounge yeah
we got the 21 plus lounge this year yeah
what are you what are you how do you get
in that sounds fun oh you can't because
the tickets are awesome we'll get you
we'll we'll get you one walk you in like
we'll get you yeah we'll get you
anywhere
yeah yeah what do you do there like what
do you think it's just it's just a party
it's just nothing and then we have like
a bunch of like uh yeah yeah like
musical acts on stage
yeah yeah okay should we go like yeah
how's the eggs experience for you
because you like it's crowded
because like you've gone to ax for like
so many years now right and it's like i
remember
i i feel like when ax was manageable
when was last time x was manageable like
15 years ago
yeah i've always been crowded and hot
and i only go to meet people because
that's where all the
weep friends gather and like yeah that's
when you can say hi to everyone so yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly but like
and aside from that's just a glorified
meet up for me pretty much well that's
the same for us as well can't go to any
panels i can't like get into anything
the lines are along everywhere you do
see some really cool cosplays yeah like
i do enjoy seeing the effort people put
into ax cosplay yeah are you guys
cosplaying
no i think i should be like powerpuff
girls
which which ones would we be
okay um
bubbles
what
blossom
i want to be buttercup
so i'm a cancer and i'm wow maybe if you
watch sharkane
maybe if i watch arcane i'll finally be
a libra buttercup i don't know you guys
too well from my experience you give off
like the most like
like comfy like wholesome vibes you give
off the most like strict like teacher
vibes and you're like a balance
why strict teacher i don't know you just
give off like a very like not a
authority how do you pronounce it
authoritarian
authoritative not too much of that but
just like a very like you're very
responsible like that kind of wow thank
you
it's just is he is he yeah
i'm getting it
i think you're being blinded by
something
i'm responsible
it's okay there's not bad being like
hufflepuff like you're like the
comfy the friendly no i'm okay with
being a hufflepuff i'm not okay with
being bubbles last time i saw you you
called me a child
don't remember in one
context the context was this we were at
the uh
anime awards the country yeah yeah we
were there the last one
why did i call you a child you must have
done something childlike no no i think
it was uh he was probably a child you're
correct by the way
he is a child what the happened but you
were like connor i'm not young i'm old
or something you said to me and then you
were like you're a child connor and i
was like i couldn't remember why this
happened but i think maybe it's because
i stole the you know we got the the
awards right you know we got there when
we opened them and yeah
i like randomly took them and then i
think what yeah so i took it home oh
what were you allowed
you know like when they they pulled out
the winner yeah yeah yeah the like kind
of sake uh barrel yeah yeah yeah
oh you mean like the demon slayer one
without you the last one yeah i just i
just took one uh
like it's cool
well they haven't had like a show since
maybe i'm the reason i broke their like
financial constraints like me stealing
this one thing
bankrupted wow that was like three years
ago
yeah that was a really slight strange
change that was yeah because i didn't go
to that crunchwall awards
before yeah i went to the one before
then you were the one before i think as
well
yeah the one in the one where we like
went on stage or something like that oh
my god yes yeah
we presented an award together i can't
remember what award it was
oh yeah i think i presented comedy right
in my mind
yeah that was oh my god yeah i did i
know he knew back then well yeah
listen as the years they start blending
together and i freak out like i've known
some of you for like i've known of you
guys for yeah yeah yeah long time it's
because we like never really like
interact
of like your own because real time was
the crunchyroll and the hentai thing
yeah it was nice
and then
yeah that yeah
it wasn't your podcast yeah i don't
think i think it's the first time yeah
yeah i think it's just like i think with
how creators are we are all aware of
each other but because we're in like
completely different circles i mean
we're like halfway across the world yeah
we're like yeah we're halfway across the
world mutual's on twitter yeah yeah
basically
yeah
it's like it's like a giant school where
i'm choosing to sit at your guys's table
today but i'm gonna go back to my team
the one time i will grace you with my
presence
so you excited for your trip to japan i
am super excited i
last time i went like it was i just
remember being well we went in november
that's a good time that's a good time
that's like one of the best times you're
going in july this time unfortunately
which is like
people don't people underestimate it so
much they're like how bad can it be no
it's bad it's it's horrible yeah during
the summer oh yeah okay yeah yeah
yeah i love how there's like so many
like especially southeast asians we're
like nah we we know what hot is
and then they go to japan they're like
i'm sorry we don't know what hot is no
it's japan somewhere like
it's worse than southeast asia it makes
southeast asia because because the thing
for me is that a lot of southeast asian
infrastructure is built around the fact
that it's going to be very very hot and
humid yeah japan less so but also i
think the humidity in japan is also
worse than
some of the times in southeast asia
is [ __ ] immediately yeah it's like
it's like 90 humidity yeah i will um
um comfort myself with the food at least
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah japanese i love
the food there
i'm in caps of ac
all the cabs have ac that's that's cool
all the trains are basically all the
trains it depends when it's super super
rammed they actually doesn't do anything
oh yeah of course but i heard that uh
one thing i liked about japan was it it
felt walkable yeah yeah or else
especially compared to here
i feel like i'm committing a crime when
i cross the road here i feel like i'm
not supposed to do it yeah a lot of the
cities here are built around cars you
know yeah there's not enough public
transportation yeah like i just want to
like pop outside go get some quick food
and here it's like do that it's it's an
effort you have to like make like a
mental commitment to go out and like
like waste like 15-20 minutes at least
you know that's at least but in japan
you could just pop out
exactly it's so good it's so good the
convenience store is amazing
i can live off of their conveniences how
many times have you been to japan no um
twice once was with pokey like it was
like five years ago was for a sponsor
but it was really fun second time was
with some friends like november like
three years did you ever leave tokyo
yeah we went to like
sorry i don't know what it's called
anymore osaka kyoto never mind we didn't
leave tokyo i guess
maybe maybe you went to different parts
of tokyo
did you take a train that was longer
than an hour
okay
didn't leave tokyo that place that
starts with an a there
no
bro yeah
yeah that's still definitely within
tokyo yes that's definitely that's like
central
[Laughter]
it was just so like nice yeah everything
tasted good everything was pretty like
anime made girls on the corner selling
you to the cafes
every type of meat cafe i do i hate this
yeah
it's it's interesting you know like yeah
yeah the cultural like shift i guess
like i could never see that in a minute
did you go to a maid cafe i didn't oh
my friends did but i did not right but
they all got like pictures with maids
michael got a picture with a maid and
she wrote her name like michael with
like
[Laughter]
yeah i forget now because we've been
living in japan for so long that
it's just normal now all right i mean
akihabara kind of got uh i don't know
wounded by the coronavirus like a lot of
stuff shut down yes sega sold off all
the arcades yeah that's so sad so it's
not called sage or anything it's not a
snake
that's it yeah okay but but it's in the
same font as the segal one yeah it's
just the same thing it's like in an
anime you know how they have like what
donald's like imagine like happen in
like real life it's like okay it's like
an alternate reality you step into but
the you know the arcades are pretty cool
uh but they're slowly just getting rid
of all the games and putting in claw
machines
yeah
arcade i think arcade culture is like
slowly done in japan that's so sad
because i still love like you know round
one yeah yeah yeah
i love our keychains that one's so good
here it's actually pretty good there's a
round one here they're really good oh i
think round one is an american company
is it not i thought it was i thought it
was japanese i'm not sure yeah i it was
one of the other i actually don't know i
don't
know
it's really good oh the one
yeah
yeah yeah
they they have a daiso here in la as
well don't they lots of things that was
so random see i didn't know i didn't
know daiso was here in l.a but it wasn't
adult all right it wasn't a dollar
um i don't know i didn't go in 75 two
dollars
so it's like going to japan and seeing a
dollar store there you know i'm just
like what oh
yeah like like a dollar tree though it's
so random to see better though
yeah because like because in australia
we have daiso as well but everything's
250.
so like it's not quite the same
nice stuff yeah i really like that so
it's nice yeah i mean i don't have rep
more than dollar tree i will say
daiso is the place you go to discover
like gadgets that you didn't know you
need until you saw it until you see it
yeah and you're like that's that's
genius and then you kind of just never
really use it anyway like it's a mop for
your face
and it looks like a normal mod i bought
that thing where like you can put like a
uh a boiled egg inside of it and then it
shuts and it perfectly cuts into like
those shoes
i used it once and i was like let's go
and then i never used it again
it's just been in the back of my cabinet
yeah i bought like the glove that's like
a washing up glass
so you could put like washing up liquid
on it and you just like basically just i
also bought this
i also bought the slippers that look
like a mop
those those
those are something i bought as well and
then i never used them because they were
useless in the end they were useless
they were just spreading out the [ __ ]
they weren't actually like collecting
anything because if you're walking on
the clean places with the moth yeah it
doesn't it doesn't work the exact same
thing it doesn't work like a model it's
not like it's not like you have a roomba
on your like specific things yeah it's
it's things though that you look at and
you're like i don't need that yeah and
then you buy and you're like all right
i'll use it once yeah because it's like
it's like all the gadgets you see on
like the infomercials or something but
like all in just like one place yeah you
know where that's that's the best way i
can describe daiso it's it's it's a one
big infomercial [ __ ]
gadget place right a church but uh of
course everything is cheap as well yeah
and whenever i need something like
really quickly like tupperware or
[ __ ] whatever paperclips whatever it
is it's just like yeah i know dust will
have it do you sell gamer shop
water bottles
in the description
with uh yeah what's your code trash tape
taste i think that's occurred right
what five percent off ten percent off
what is it
a
[Laughter]
oh my god this is thank you for doing
our ad for us
[Laughter]
i feel more rejuvenated oh my god
so you talked about japanese food being
really good but i i think like the la
food culture is also really good right
yeah i think one of the best parts about
living in l.a is like you want like
indian food you can get really good
indian food you want japanese food you
want like chinese food like you're so
that it's so diverse yeah yeah someone
who specializes in like each cuisine was
the british food though
what beans on toast
was fish fish and chips i want you to
bring up british food with michael he
will [ __ ] on it so far
i'm so sorry he just hates british food
i'll keep her like i'll i'll go to him
and i'll be like really serious about it
and i'll be like oh please but have you
has he had a testimony
then you haven't had proper british food
for you to mention british food to my
god
do you know how many times he's made fun
of you jellied eels that's not a thing
yeah but that's like that's low-hanging
fruit yeah that is low-hanging he says
that you guys like colonize india with
spices but the best thing you could
think of is beans on toast like he just
ships
constantly i'm like have you ever been
to britain he's like no have you
no
why not
i've been to uh
and the only place in europe i've been
to germany that's it
for like gamescom or something no no no
it's just like some sponsor thing i
don't remember i did not like that
still water i had to pay for it i kept
asking sparkly sparkling water just
tastes like spicy water to me i don't
like it
yeah you have to specify like tap
tap
water
yeah no i kept paying like three euros
oh my god
i think i did last day i just stayed in
my hotel and ordered room service oh no
uk's fun i do want to visit uk i think
it's yeah one of the places i want to
visit eventually yeah do you think i
could get away with an accident
[Music]
give it a shot
okay you keep talking about something
though hi uh yeah so you like beans and
toast yeah oh i love beans and bees and
toast
you sound like uh like you got rejected
for a crown audition
what is this i'm rooting for the part of
queen elizabeth uh oh yes i know it's on
toast people actually eat beans on toast
yes yeah people do eat beans literally
like my one growing up obviously because
it's really easy to make you just
do the [ __ ] breakfast food at the
hotel it's just nothing but beans
sausages and beans on toast
i mean like beans on taste by itself or
so
yeah sometimes you would have that but
it normally always came with cheese on
top yeah you would so my mum would
always make it like maybe like once a
week it would always be like beans toast
cheese and then a fried egg on top and
then you put brownies that sounds good
yeah and that's [ __ ] good yeah that's
that's i love that normally i have beans
on toast with like a full full english
breakfast yeah the full english stuff
and then yeah
that's coagulated blood i think right
it's just it's a blood yeah
my parents bought me a mcdonald's
breakfast
honestly i [ __ ] with mcdonald's
breakfast it's so [ __ ] good cakes are
perfect
i don't rate them
okay okay
we were getting the sausage
right right i thought i thought we were
like bonding over something you have to
mention pancakes their pancakes are
perfectly circular it's perfect no i am
like against eating pancakes thank you
thank you i don't think it's a breakfast
like not it's cake yeah it is it's cake
it's it's like americans have tricked
each other into eating dessert for
breakfast
yeah i like them oh my girls are so good
it's like a pancake by this bun
chicken mcgriddle i just feel like you
have a a pancake obsession i love
pancakes do you like ihope
yeah i hopes ruined pancakes they are
kind of mid honestly what would you say
is a place that has good pancakes then
like pancake specialty restaurants you
could probably yelp and look it up like
oscars pancake bar or something like
that
so you have it for breakfast or just
like any time i'm an adult i can eat it
anytime i want
but i drink like i really like the
standard like a bowl of rice some soup
maybe like some grilled fish or meat egg
kimchi i don't know that's like a good
breakfast to me yeah yeah oh i thought
you had that with pancake i was like
that's a
that's a lot of carbs
yeah it is very carb heavy like pancakes
waffles like cereal it's all sugar and
soda for you i can't believe we
normalized that growing up like i can't
believe that was normal what
pancakes for breakfast yeah i know yeah
it's weird
that's what that's what i'm trying to
say that's what we're trying to say yeah
i like bread bread for breakfast it's
pretty good
you're very european yeah but like it's
just pancakes are a little bit different
yeah the syrup like savory bread is
great like just some toast or just
eat some of it i love it i just don't
even know what i'm so hungry now
i shouldn't have said that yeah
holy crap i'm hungry yeah luckily i'm
not a breakfast person like breakfast is
the meal i probably eat the least uh
because i don't know some like
i i feel like a full english or
something is [ __ ] great and then
american breakfast is great as well but
it's just like so heavy especially like
japanese breakfast when you go to like a
ryokan and you have like a proper
japanese breakfast
it's like a three-course meal it's kind
of breakfast yeah yeah yeah it's too
much it's cheap
yeah but also english breakfast is too
much i remember like day three of mcn
and i was having the breakfast uh the
hotel breakfast yeah and it was like a
full plate of like make your own english
breakfast dude by like 12 p.m i'm so
sick because it's so like it's so oily
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's a lot of
oil in the morning
yeah it's like when you've had
everything like like a long day of
drinking and then the next day you're
like i get amazing hangover food yeah it
is
it's like it's like that's that's why
it's a british breakfast right perfect
hangover food but like you eat every day
and it's just way too heavy it's so ugh
yeah i mean i do like miso soup in the
morning though that is like this is just
yeah you can't go wrong with that
okay like that's it though i only need
miso soup i don't need anything else
just one miso soup
maybe like a small bowl of rice do you
know uh tonjiru do you know that it's
like it's miso soup with like pork and
like veggies oh but that sounds like a
pork broth
what's your favorite food to eat when
you go to japan sushi sushi okay okay
yeah i remember two like when i went to
a poke the first time and i like this
underground subway whatever we're hungry
i'm like oh there's a sushi place let's
just go there yeah go there eat it's
omakase and i'm like this is so good
like it's just like a random hole in the
wall place that we sat down and yeah no
like sushi is [ __ ] incredible in
japan because of course it is right but
like i even i i like even think like the
cheap conveyor belt
those are my favorite actually because i
love like you know the omakase set and
everything like that but like
i want to just sometimes you just want
to [ __ ] stuff yourself with like good
sushi and like
even though you're just playing like a
dollar for like the conveyor belt sushi
it's better than like it's slapstick
it's better than most places you can
find abroad honestly yep
a single bean
no it is not beans on rice beans on rice
it's the same thing
sorry it's her royal majesty's spam
that's [ __ ] hawaii
yeah now what was the uh was it yo sushi
is that that oh that's [ __ ] that was
the worst one in abomination
something something like british and
like sushi shouldn't like no no no no
it should have been but sometimes in
america there's good sushi here too yeah
sometimes i just really want like a
deep-fried california roll topped with
like baked salmon and like drizzled with
three different i feel like that's not
even sushi though like one like i feel
like they're both different types of
sushi but i like i like bubbles yeah i
like boats yeah yeah that's really good
i i personally don't count that as sushi
but like i won't say no to a california
yeah because because because you can't
get it in like japanese not getting
japan no like they don't know california
rules in japan no no no no i think i
think you'd be like killed yeah
i mean they will put avocado in my mouth
no [ __ ] no
[Laughter]
well these these dudes try to train like
15 years to slap rice around yeah like
they're not they're not gonna put like
avocado on it no but it's delicious like
cream cheese
yeah okay yeah but like again i don't
count that as sushi i know it's it's a
good meal but like yeah actually i think
it's kind of like it's like an american
taste no i have seen one place that
sells california roles yeah because like
99 of sushi places you go to don't even
do roles you know it's like roles just
like don't really exist in japan just
like cut like maki i guess yeah yeah
yeah that's that's like the closest
you're gonna get oh god i'm so excited
to eat food there i'm so hungry right
now sushi is like my favorite food of
all time
going to japan is like i'm just going to
eat sushi every single day
every day and you're never going to get
bored of it because i actually won't i
thought i would buy like like sushi is
the one japanese meal where i ate sushi
before moving to japan and i ate it more
after moving japan yeah just like have
not got bored of it that's all
yeah
but like
what's like
aside from sushi is there anything else
you like about japanese food like do you
write ramen oh okay i like instant ramen
more than regular ramen
that you you know what the [ __ ] i think
it's just what is
that you could say maybe ramen's too
heavy normally yeah it's too much but
saying it's better i like the taste i
like the taste i don't think you've been
to a good wrong way
in l.a i go to a ramen place right and
it looks good and i'm like can i have an
extra egg please and they're like oh
that'll be three dollars and i'm like
can i have like why are you speaking in
british
like seaweed and you're like oh yeah
that's dollar fifty and you gave me like
one type
why would all the toppings so expensive
bro yeah but does it taste good but does
it taste good it's good but it's just
like i i think instant ramen it fits my
palate more i don't know i just i think
you need to go to like a proper good
ramen place in japan have you tried
zucchini that's the best one yeah
yeah but there's nothing like you know
it's like one a.m you're sad as [ __ ] you
bring out the pot you open the shin ram
in black you know yeah
i [ __ ] love shin ramen yeah with the
egg and the cheese yeah
it just hits but i mean like it's not
like korean flavored sorry yeah i like
cream
i think we found it yeah we figured it
out we figured it out
luckily you know the japanese ramen
stores are open like 24 7. normally oh
yeah you guys are there this place is
open until like 4 a.m yeah you go there
yeah
ramen in japan and i do remember it
being very delicious so maybe it's been
like so long
is it because it's not spicy enough in
japan um
shin ram is like pretty spicy so
is korean ramen yeah
yeah i did order like non-spicy so maybe
that's funny yeah there's a lot of
places to do spicy ramen i will try that
next time maybe you should go to the
place the corner and i went to what's it
called oh no no okay never mind that was
like the saddest ramen scottish hot
hottest scottish scottish
fries the accent the accent sorry you
just pour whiskey into it
since it's a broth of like
whiskey
i
okay that's good that's just pancakes i
mean you love pancakes right i love
pancakes no you guys don't rate
okonomiyaki okay i i think it's okay i
didn't think it was bad i just think
it's okay i
[Music]
arcane so i'm unsure
should we take that back then you're
associating with the bad tape man
um those these days i feel anime it's
really hard for me to find an anime that
i like and i will keep watching because
like like older again i'm just i don't
have time anymore it has to be really
good for me to
stay so right now the only thing i'm
really enjoying kind of is like spikes
family yeah that's super fun to watch
yeah so it's like everyone yeah yeah i i
think it's just like i don't know how
it's gotten so popular so quickly but i
think it's just like a show that
everyone unanimously agrees it's just
really
good yeah yeah i've not yeah i've not
heard of a single person calling it mid
and that's like a first for shown in
anime dude oh my god this ax is just
going to be all your for
the spy family cause this is just my
favorite
spy family no it's going to be the year
of genting
because we
we
playing oh my god we were we were at mcm
which is like the british uh like uh
comic con and pretty much every third
cosplayer was against the character yeah
yeah crazy how like popular genshin is
like that's insane yes do you play
genjin um well okay so i don't i know
anything used to and i got cast yeah i
went in this gentian rabbit hole i was
like playing the game i was spending
money i was rolling for five star
characters i was watching genji mmds on
youtube
like it was bad
i'm like yeah i like yeah so you said
you became a full-on gentian in yeah
addicts i was like i was like that
sounds normal up until the mmd
i'm not proud of it i had a day where
i'm just like look i just did people
just the i think the models are free to
use right they like they're good
yeah they share like the models and so
so people take the character models and
make them dance to like cute japanese
sweet songs and stuff yeah and i'm like
oh it's kind of cute and i just kept
clicking now we've literally like gone
full circle we've reverted back to like
the miku days now yeah where where you'd
have all like the old og mm mmds of like
miku characters oh the vocaloid
oh my god oh my god that was so big back
then yeah wow man
somehow genji's brought that like
[ __ ] phase back now i didn't know
yeah the nico nico era is back yeah yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah so is genji in your
first gatcha
okay game i've played lots of gotcha
games and i stopped because i have a
problem yeah um i play summoner's war
for a bit oh that's notorious for being
a money city wow wow
cookie run okay i'm like oh this looks
really fun let me try it and i installed
it and i'm like i need the five-star
cookies and i just keep
this it's terrible what's the what's the
most you've spent on a theatre game
let's just say that i spent more than
what they paid me to avoid no i was i
was about to ask it's like the worst
thing that can happen to you you get
casted in the catcher game because that
means you're like obligated to play the
game you're gonna get really really into
it i basically paid back the
money it's like a circular economy right
that's how it works that's just money
laundering
i stopped spending money like okay i
stopped playing because i had to get
installed like clicking around and again
yeah i find the best way to make sure i
never play a gadget game is
yeah that but if i promote it they give
you like a cracked account right yeah
and then it just ruins the game because
you're like because then you're like
well i have everything yeah and now
there's no point in me getting my credit
card out yeah it's better
at like making enticing you to like look
at all those gunshit character demos i
really have like tons of people's jobs
to just find out what will make you most
addicted it's just it's very well done
to be fair like the characters are
beautiful the sound music everything
like i'm not a gunshin chill i swear but
like
it's just really pretty like yeah the
aesthetics are nice yeah i mean like i
think there's a lot of good things about
genshin but i'm also like an extension
player i've also got out i'm i've i've
been like one year gentian free now i'm
i'm very happy
[Laughter]
[Music]
you need to come to more of these
therapy sessions
i played it i just never really like got
into it i kind of just played around and
i kind of had a little bit of fun yeah
it never really hooked me i think like
um the world of kenshin like surpasses
like with the actual game like people
like cosplaying it drawing it
music all of that is way stronger yeah
the community isn't community is crazy
yeah like the community is crazy and
it's like a really like titanic like
cool community from what i've seen as
well
and yeah but like well i think what got
me into gen chin or what saw me on
kenshin was actually just i don't know
the feeling it gave you like
it's like the combination of just like
the landscape and like the music was
like so [ __ ] beautiful
and like you didn't really get that in
the first area but when you discovered
leeway oh my god that's what that's when
the game actually got like good for me
you know
like but that's the exact reason those
are the exact reasons why i just opted
to play breath of the wild over against
you breath of the wild because it's like
it's the exact same feeling but in my
opinion the gameplay is way more fun it
is yeah but um and i think that's a big
reason why i'm like like the cute girls
almost got me they almost got me until i
saw the price tag
i've already completed breath of the
wild and i don't know when the [ __ ]
breath of the wild 2 is coming out it
just feels like like nice little niche
you know because it's getting gentian is
like infinite content well it's not
really infinite content
but you know it makes you feel like it
for the last time but then you realize
it becomes like a like a part-time job
yeah and that's when you know you're
addicted you know anything that'll stop
me from playing league i'll take it
league isn't that bad i swear
i still play league often not often
what why do you still want to play it
it's like it's like it's like your
ex-girlfriend
okay okay so you're in an abusive
relationship it's not abusive we just
like maybe it's better if we part but
then i miss them i'm like hey what are
you doing
it's like the ex-girlfriend that never
leaves the conversation out it's like
it's like yeah this is cool but my ex i
think uh moving to japan kind of killed
it for me wow
because uh you the servers suck yeah and
also no one really plays no one plays no
no one plays
popular in japan it's it's the i think
the least popular server but the people
on the server are just from china and
korean like smurfing
you don't get a game and then when you
get a game this guy who's like
apparently iron one like lease in
perfectly like insect kicks you and
you're like you're like all right okay
[ __ ] i guess i'm just bad also it's the
most toxic service oh it's never
experienced oh my god i kinda wanna try
this it's just it's just because you
know i mean i feel like asians are like
really rude to each other like the
different types of asians
yes yes
and and when this and when a server is
full of people not from that country to
just like take over that country it
becomes
a top successful yeah i think like any
other league server is toxic it's
nothing compared to the japanese servers
so uh emily and didis just moved to
japan and died still wants to play
league and he's been sending me
screenshots of like all his chat logs
from the game yeah and it's just full on
just like people going at it yeah
arguing
like it's like no one on the japanese
servers speaks japanese
i've never seen japanese in the it's
always chinese or
yeah wow
oh yeah that would kill my desire too
yeah yeah so i was kind of like yeah i'm
kind of over this i'd play tft
now i like tf2
but it's so it's such a bad viewer game
like
trying to get a new audience to watch
tft is is like
welcome to my algebra class three here's
a morgana
i think it's the best but it's like a
new set just comes out that's what the
viewership i think because everyone's
like curious
yeah because i i try to like follow tft
i have no idea what the hell is going on
so it just becomes like if if they're
streaming with a mate then it just
becomes like a glorified just chatting
stream which i i wish i could follow you
know but if it's just like someone
screaming tft i'm like
but even as someone who played it a lot
like i was uh like diamond one at one
point at tft and then the next set i'm
completely clueless yeah i'm like
so it's like even if i get really really
really good in one set i'm completely
[ __ ] bad the moment they change
everything right
everything i learned was all like muscle
memory and now i don't know anything and
now it's really hard to get back into it
this episode is sponsored by expressvpn
guys have you ever read the fine print
that appears when you start browsing in
incognito mode no well it says that your
activity might still be visible to your
employer your school or your internet
service provider what how can you even
call that incognito to really stop
people from seeing the sites you visit
you need to do what i do and use
expressvpn think of all the times you've
used wi-fi at a coffee shop a hotel
where we are right now or even at your
parents house without especially bn
every site you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network and in the us
where we currently are right now oh god
um they can legally sell your data to
other third parties expressvpn is an app
that encrypts all your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
servers so that your private online
activity stays just that private so stop
letting strangers know what you're
getting up to go to
expressvpn.com trash taste that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n dot com slash trash
taste to get an extra three months for
free thank you special epm for
sponsoring the episode back to the show
do you play like uh you play valorant or
[ __ ] valerie
i've had to ban the word bad yes oh
i banned the wood valerian in my twitch
chat what really because i don't people
are like hey you want to play valor i'm
like don't [ __ ] ask me if i want to
play that this game [ __ ] sucks all
right let me tell my violin sucks all
right okay
all right so you join this lobby you're
locked into like an hour the game is
like an hour it's so [ __ ] like is it
[Music]
let's say you join you're new it's like
the worst game to play when you're new
because it's like there's nothing to
keep you engaged you go in this game you
immediately get head shotted through a
wall by like a 12 year old korean kid
and then you're waiting watching someone
else play you're like oh dude nice dude
he carried me awesome next round you
spend you spend all your money on a gun
you go out you get shot again you're
like what the [ __ ] man let me just play
the game
i know i feel like league is the worst
experience for new players that's just
me oh yeah because like
it's worse i i tried it once because
like it's horrible with valerian at
least it's a first person shooter
everyone knows how to play first places
chapters you point around you you click
on something and then it dies or you get
killed yeah you learn it easier yeah
league is like there's how many
champions are there now yeah yeah like
like not good like if i didn't play
league when i was like in university
there would be no way i'd be playing
league now because the learning curve
for that is [ __ ] ridiculous okay
would you play valerian if you had to
play it alone though
i play solo queue do you sometimes the
voice com is hilarious i'm like hey guys
any mic and you're like shut the [ __ ] up
and it's like such good content that's
that's fair in japan you no one talks i
you do the amount of effort i have to do
to get someone to talk on japanese voice
chat oh on apex i can sometimes get them
to talk that's so it's like it feels
like a different like they don't talk
so like like when you play like i don't
know like when you did you play
overwatch yeah like in ranked everyone
used to always talk like it was like if
you didn't have a mic you were like the
guy who's bringing the team down okay
right like in ranked but then like the
moment i went after japan no one [ __ ]
uses their mic ever
you have to really like they're just
really shy they are they are it's just
the culture they just don't do it like
it's just not normal to like that's why
japanese are like have really bad
esports because they they don't talk
they don't communicate they're
communicating
you know watch japanese esports teams
they're just like silent
it was the was it the ballarat japanese
team what's it called they're pretty
correct they're insane they're very good
yeah okay yeah i don't follow the
japanese or the valerian esports scene
unfortunately only league that's enough
for me but they don't talk to each other
probably i don't know probably just like
telepathy or something [ __ ]
what's your favorite game then
that's not kenshin
i likely just because like i played it
for so long and i started my youtube
career pretty much on legal so it means
a lot to me yeah but
again it's like you know you've been
dating this person for like 10 years and
it's like it's time to let go
but you do have good times with them
it's not like you don't have good times
with them
sorry real desperate
i swear i have a good time you like you
don't play ranked much anymore right
because that's when like i feel like the
game is at its worst but also at its
best in a way playing with if you have a
full stack it could be fun but that's
this case with valerian as well stack
make friends make things fun right no
but leaks one of those games as well
while i feel like if there's one person
in your lobby who's like really high
ranked or on your team it's really hard
to like play with them yeah and it's
like how do you i'm not gonna pick my
friends based on their elo like i'm not
a i'm not a weirdo can you just make
smurfs yeah i guess
yeah yeah i mean like
that's kind of like why i never really
get into competitive games because
there's always like the initial hump
where you start learning a new game it's
really fresh it's really fun
and then like the moment that game dies
for me is when i like pressed like it
started going on the ranked ladder and
then that's when it like the game stops
from being fun to just being like a
choice
like a stressful experience like it's
it's like a friendship ender at some
point if you if you go it seems like a
nice idea in your head oh yeah let's
let's rank up together guys and then
like you
like if you want to test your friendship
you go into a ranked game with your
friends on league that will test your
friendship right because not everyone's
gonna be the same skill level right yeah
yeah and so if someone you will fight
you will find out who the toxic people
in your friend who are by playing ranked
ladder together weed out the toxic yeah
literally
do you like uh i don't know okay have
you ever heard of pokemon puzzle league
pokemon puzzles this sounds really
familiar yeah why does it sound familiar
a tetris attack yeah yeah it's like that
but pokemon oh
there's pc only
what's it got to do with pokemon
nintendo 64. oh
oh okay okay
i love that game so much but no one
plays it it's like you know when you
have like oh yeah because it was like
when the dinosaurs were okay but like
to this day when you go to packs or
whatever some comments sometimes they
have like texas attack tournaments and
stuff like that yeah
that's yeah it's one of those games that
i think i'm like really good at but like
so i stopped playing it um
could you still win now would you win i
think i could win did you like speed
some people i don't know
what's the player base for this game
right yeah
it's just lilly
no one else there's a free world record
up here people who still like it but
they're just scattered so now i'm trying
to like get better at valerie because
everyone plays malaran right yeah so if
you're good at valorant you know you
look cool man like
fps
i'm gonna like like music rhythm games
or stuff like that but like that's not
that's not cool it's it's battle around
japan is really [ __ ] cool in japan
[Music]
but then you've realized how [ __ ] you
are when you go to town you see some of
the people
yeah yeah yeah just see those you just
see those [ __ ]
yeah i know every time you go everyone
is like serious about it everyone has
like their custom gear like yeah
you go to one of the boobs and they
bring out the [ __ ] glove or something
are you like god damn you know
it's like when i go to like you know
like ddr pump it up machines yeah you
come with like towels and like water
bottles and like backpacks yeah you're
camping oh my god
you know you know shit's about to get
like [ __ ] up when like the it's always
like it's never the guys who are like
fully fully in shape that are the best
the ddr it's like the guys who are like
you know just come out to the arcade you
should just play dudes
there's some big dudes that i've seen i
remember this like one kind of like
larger gentleman in all sucker who just
went up to a ddr machine like huge
bottle of water big towel and he was it
would look like it was about to like
work out and everyone at that arcade was
like
hold on guys
something something magical is about to
happen he was absolutely tearing us and
there's like 30 people surrounding him
just being like i will challenge you and
he's just like all right step up
honestly sometimes it's intimidating
though because sometimes i just want to
like try out like a nice rhythm yeah you
should try it no i do i do love the
rhythm games but like sometimes you see
someone like tear it up in this rhythm
game and i'm just like i don't know how
to get it to start like
he sucked too in the beginning that's me
with like fighting games though at all
because it's like i always want to try
it yeah but there's always a [ __ ]
prodigy 10 year old on the other side
ready to kick my ass all right
also they smoke at those in japan
oh and some of them they do a lot of
them a lot of the ones with the fighting
games on the floor you can smoke if it's
especially like
it'll be like no smoke on any of the
floor the fighting game floor you can
smell it there'll be ash trays and stuff
and so just it reeks of smoke though
yeah but in the middle of that there's
always that one 10 year old who's just
destroying everyone
it's it's really interesting i feel like
you see like you see like a almost
authentic side of japan in the arcade
yeah everyone kind of just like come
into this place and just let off some
steam yeah interesting it's the best
yeah i think like the fighting game
community in japan is like way bigger
than say like
what's like what's what's like smash
i don't know you say smash big in japan
it was
big right i like the at the peak i think
right like there was a lot of like like
high level competitors going to like big
smash tournaments in the us and right
evo and [ __ ] but
i don't know about now
i don't know any game where you don't
need to converse with someone to be good
at it like that that's that's that's
like big in japan you know so rhythm
games fighting games like massive in
japan
no words necessary only fists
it's just like because they want to like
they want to do one thing and they just
want to perfect it yeah it's like the
very japanese way of thinking it's like
i just want to redo the same thing and
just get very good at this one skill not
to prove it to anyone just to prove it
it's like a self rewarding feeling i'm
not really sure why like it's kind of
very zen right yeah yeah yeah it works
yeah like i i really want to get into
fighting games but there's such a big
massive jump from just randomly mashing
buttons yeah to like
being even like a competent like being
like just mildly competent of fighting
games that's such a big [ __ ] gap hard
mm-hmm yeah i'm getting better at smash
because i just wanted to beat the people
at the party you know at the party
there's always a smash yeah yeah yeah i
just wanted to beat like some people
that was my threshold did you ever get
to that point i don't know there were no
parties culvert hit
it's like all the training got to waste
i think the only time because joey's
like one of the chillest guys i know i
think one of the only times i've seen
joey like genuinely tilted and angry is
during smash why you played connor
oh yeah
this [ __ ] kept playing king k
rool and just [ __ ] down being every
time
i love characters with characters it
feels so fun it's like why would i want
to hit you when i can make you hear
yourself it's the only time i've ever
thrown a controller on the ground oh i'm
just like [ __ ] really something about
smash the other day
the other day i was on youtube and then
there's like these whole smash
compilations yeah they're my favorite
they're so funny this is so funny it's
like this whole world opened up and i
just started clicking for like three
hours like the saltiest moment
compilations of smash tournaments
one of ludwig's most popular videos is
that he made a compilation of like top
10 saltiest ice climber moments i think
really yeah and that's like his most
popular videos i didn't even know he
made that video
honestly like part of the reasons i want
to get into fighting games because the
fighting game community just seems so
fun
like i've seen like so many compilations
on youtube or just like fighting game
community moments and it's just i don't
know how can i how can you describe it
it's the perfect mix of just cancer
toxicity but also like no one takes it
too seriously as well yeah passionate
they're very passionate there's a really
funny clip i think it was like a street
fighter 2 tournament or something and
like some convention and there's just
like two people fighting yeah a huge
crowd and this kid just gets absolutely
[ __ ] destroyed and then just from the
back just some guy just goes get that
boy some milk
and then he just became a thing in the
fighting game community as like a thing
to just be like he's tilted get that
voice of milk because like you know
gaming now right it's very like it's
been kind of like polished a bit you
know you can't trash talk as much online
yeah
yeah yeah and then now and but like
that's why i feel like the fighting game
is such a cool place it's like you just
trash talk
yeah yeah yeah exactly right i love that
yeah it's kind of like it's kind of like
you know like a real like ufc file yeah
yeah yeah yeah where people were trash
talking
part of like the entertainment right
like safe trash talking for nerds and no
one gets hurt it's great i love it i
love it i i miss trash talk on video
games yeah i like that do you not do
that anymore on the like i can't now
like what's more like films maybe
what about apex what about
when they're like really mean to me i
just type
like it pisses them off
like are you talking to me
it's like somehow more aggravating yeah
that's worse than trash talk yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's natural i feel bad
saying like yeah you're [ __ ] you know
what this just feels no no that's
unoriginal you have to come up with like
five oh okay um yeah it's hard like i'm
trying to focus on the game how can i
think of witty insults like
that's that's weird i mean valerian
writes you're dead for like most of the
time i'm here just like spitballing
ideas i'm like yo i'm trying to like
test these ideas i'm messaging friends
like what do you think this is good
oh i'm up he's going deep into the
insult book yeah yeah yeah
yeah well i'm just that guy who's just
like let's try our best guys
we can win this that's why i don't play
call of games because i'm that guy yeah
they're just like shut
will say one thing i hate about valerian
it's like why it's like one skin for a
gun like [ __ ] like 30 bucks what's up
with that
they gotta dude they're a small company
they need to make money
right small car
that was the one thing i was like what
the [ __ ] even league isn't this bad i
mean get league sometimes they love skin
prestige skins yeah yeah okay those are
pretty gross
i i um you remember elemental slugs yeah
yeah that was like four thirty dollars
yeah it was a lot yeah so i love 30
bucks
for one skin but it's like okay well
it's not just one skin it's like tense
in the game you can change to an element
and it changes the whole skin and then
you can change the nut to another
element if those elements mix it makes
another element and there's ten in total
and each one has different voice lines
so it's actually ten skins and one
doesn't change anything about the way
the characters played no no no no no
okay because if it did then it wouldn't
it would break the game just like
aesthetic so yeah so it's just a really
elaborate aesthetic
yeah but it's really pretty it's my
favorite champion i was really excited
so i got it and i asked my friend do you
want one i think everyone should try it
right so i gave him one and then i asked
another friend i'm like do you want one
too i spent
i gave like five friends like elementary
oh
i used to always get the 490 mystery
skins
i used to love that i don't know i'm
just it's like a mystery box it's a
mystery you're playing
you were into gotcha are you telling me
you were into gotcha because i wanted
skins but i didn't want to feel like i
was paying full price
because if i did that i would feel
ashamed so you got a skin that you
probably didn't even play really what do
you mean i love one of the udia skins
that isn't spirit guard
i love those
that's you know when you get a skin from
malphite and it would be like the you
know he has like that one what is it
like the shamrock one that one is so
[ __ ] shamrock
they would like just recall him green
and be like kids shamrock
but it was just like early league skins
they just recolored it and called it
something else but now it's just a shiny
pokemon yeah yeah yeah you have stepped
it up
yeah i mean now everyone just looks but
all the girls now they make them look
the same in like every skin it's kind of
weird yeah i know but they're still
pretty like i know i know about this but
like my eyes are glazed over when i see
like sparkles and pretty colors
is is the skins what makes she comes
back to play league whenever whenever
like a new skin like gets released and
you're like damn that looks good do you
only play cute champions i'm not gonna
that's so that does check out i'll just
check out it's like i know the answers
to this but obviously obviously as
somebody who's been doing league stuff
for a really long time you know league
is kind of going into more of like an
anime direction i noticed do you like
that hell yeah yeah you know i think
they should just go full weeb honestly
at this point just just do it i do wish
they had a little more monsters though i
do like the monsters there's monsters
did you see that mommy the bellevue
they're not pretty to look
is like my favorite character oh he's
like a big bubble gum he's just great
like he's fun i love how he plays it's
great but they know i think it's also
what sells so like yeah yeah star
guardian yeah yasuros and all those kind
of samurai boys i mean i mean like
league and weeb culture or all leagues
and weeps have always like just meshed
one to one
yeah leagues and weaves right it's like
weeps in the middle there's a shoe over
here oh so you know you're indeed if
you're an issue
yeah because like i remember even before
like in the early days of league pretty
much
pretty much everyone who played league i
felt watched anime as well because like
i i'd see so many like people just
talking about anime in my chat you know
when i when i would play league and i
was like oh this is where all the anime
fans are because i couldn't find them in
real life they're all playing league
yeah it'd be like hisoka fan 69 or
something oh because everyone was
playing yasuo right and you know that if
you're a yasuo player you definitely
watch
the word yasuo in my chat
no when you type in yasuo it's just a
it's an emote of someone puking
really hate that champion i
firmly believe that him being created
like dampened my game experience and
made me play like less i hate yeah you
make it sound like i killed it
uh no what's his what's his brother
called uh i hate yoni no no i think
jonah's way worse than yesterday i know
it's like they took everything that was
bad about yasuo and they like they made
it even worse in yone i hate those two
champions so much like every time i see
it i don't even want to play anymore so
to explain yasuo to you joe yeah please
okay yasuo is a samurai right
that's it he's he's a he's a very high
skill cap samurai champion right
so huh sorry no sorry high school cup
it's just a really funny way
how would you say it
he's a character you want to play when
you want to be like edgy like you want
to look flashy and [ __ ] everyone wants
to be better than they are yeah he's
just very he's a he is a difficult
character
yeah so like how how it always plays out
is when you are against an enemy yasuo
they're like [ __ ] god mode yasuo they
will go like they will [ __ ] solo kill
your entire team and like make you
slowly lose the game right but when a
yasuo is on your team it's guaranteed by
like the force of nature that there will
be the reason you lose the game [ __ ]
yeah they'll go 0-10 and then they'll
flame everyone for like for like sucking
up the game right yeah yasuo plays like
the worst
it's the same thing but with a bunch of
more [ __ ] yeah even more like weird
[ __ ] like self-healing more shields when
it came out i was like in shock i'm like
i don't have two bands i only have one
yeah i mean all the new characters they
release are nuts like i just yeah like
i hate zoey i hate yeah talia all that
[ __ ] even though that's old now but yeah
i know i know but like ever since like
that point onwards i was kind of like i
do think like as league gets bigger they
have like over 160 champions yeah
there's only so many kids they can make
yeah and like how are you going to make
each one more unique i guess yeah it
definitely feels like they keep making
it even crazier and crazy like the new
one they announced look just like stupid
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] like
dashing like everywhere like even more
than normal now yeah or what's the
samira as well i didn't really like it
i'm like what the [ __ ] is samira doing
oh
yeah
yeah
joey looks so lost right now he's like
100 i'm just live and dude
yeah because like the only way i find
out about new champions now is because
like when you when i followed like the
esports scene and i see a new champion i
just like i have no idea oh my god they
picked it they picked the thing and
they're like oh what is it i
do you still follow the esports scene at
all yeah
why would you you're from the na server
right
i said it okay i said it wrong
i do think back in the day like i'm
talking like season three for ish there
were more story lines i could i could
follow you knew everyone yeah yeah yeah
or whatever yeah no it's like i just
lost track i don't know yeah
yeah pretty much you just like follow
faker and uh yeah i can't believe faker
is still like
playing
i know i wonder what's gonna happen to
league when he retires he's like the god
of league of legends at this point
that's insane so faker's like i guess
what's what's the call like the michael
jordan of like league i guess that's
like what's what's what's like the
michael jordan yeah i mean that's fair
enough i mean like i'm trying to think
of like a really like a really great
player yeah yeah he's like notorious for
being i've heard the name faker yeah
yeah because his name i guess almost
like transcends league itself because
you you might not know nothing about
league but you've heard the name faker i
know that i'm fake yeah yeah yeah yeah i
think he chose such a good name too to
be like that icon like faker it sounds
so cool i can't watch his streams though
it makes me sick watching him like with
the camera what happened like he whips
the camera all around it's like
impossible to watch yeah he's like he
like flicks around everywhere and it's
it's it's nauseating to watch yeah so he
has like hockeys so he has hotkeys where
he can like flick to like different
champions or like his teammates
yeah yeah he uses them but he flicks to
like a teammate for like a microsecond
and somehow that's enough time to garner
the information he needs
i'm just like this is what happens when
you're like just jacked into the matrix
is it you talking about this edit where
like it's something where like he's in a
a fight and instead of flicking someone
edits it so he's opening up
solitude like solitaire while fighting
it's so good
because it looks real it looks so good
yeah but like yeah i can't watch your
streams but you know it's like pretty
much jumping he's please be jumping
while playing league as well probably
it's great watching him play jump king
and pogo stuck because you're like you
are human it's nice to see you're not a
god game it's like you see him fall a
[ __ ] ton of jump king you're like that's
really comforting
the best guy in the world at this game
also struggled with that one's [ __ ]
jumping jump king yeah
have you finished jump king no
he hasn't so you both have them yeah
yeah probably never to touch that game
it was
it reminded me of that other game
what it's a game like that getting over
it getting over it yes yes no no jump
king's way harder junking's way higher
oh really yeah yeah they're both hard
and they both i gave up on both of them
it's like somehow jump king even though
it's like a rage game it's still like
we're always getting back to it yeah
it's still like less rage inducing to me
than some league servers yeah or some
league games you know i must say it was
definitely the most one of the most
satisfying moments when i beat that game
in recent history
yeah
it was really good would you would you
do the uh expansions though no
i i i prioritize my happiness so uh no
thank you
i say that and i'm probably going to
it's like a drug yeah it was the worst
carpal tunnel i ever got from playing
jump king i've never gotten carpal
tunnel oh my god well i play because you
play with the keyboard yeah i was doing
it i played with control
so i could sit back that's smart yeah i
should have done that [ __ ] tom yeah
okay at least she watched her king
yeah at least i did watch arcane that's
true i'm so sorry
i can't believe you didn't watch it
i can't believe it i can't believe it's
brought up again
watch it here oh yeah i mean this is the
only tv it's the only tv
unfortunately somehow we have this like
[ __ ]
like [ __ ] mansion in l.a and this is
this is like one tv we've only got one
tv and no curtains beautiful place so
you guys picked a nice place
you guys want to like
stay in comfort yeah yeah
who doesn't want to stay here uber was
driving and like the neighborhoods were
getting nicer
every uber driver that's dropped me off
he was like what are you what are you
doing
where are we like
it's really nice but then i feel the
obligation to like have to tip way more
than normal because they're like they're
like oh what do you do and i'm like no
i'm not there
i'm a youtuber no do you tell did you
tell people that no no no but this is
how the conversation goes like oh do you
work i'm like no no no oh what do you do
i work from home oh what do you do from
home oh i just like you know making my
videos oh like on youtube
leads up to that and i'm like i need to
just think of a different profession
every time i i was uh talking to an uber
driver he was kind of like a he seemed
like a really interesting dude yeah
quite a character i'd say and uh so i
just started asking him questions
because i really want to hear his
opinion on things
he's from l.a
of course when you're a strange person i
feel like you're like born and raised
here i was like uh i should ask him a
few things first of all i was like do
you like l.a he's like [ __ ] no
i was like oh why'd you live here he's
like man i don't know i can't leave man
and i was like all right that's what
they all say
everyone
i want to move to miami and become a
youtuber oh i was like i was like yeah
man what kind of videos did you make
he's like just writing chicks
i was like i was like what do you mean
like he's like he was like you know just
say how how the girls are talk about
them yeah yeah yeah you'll make a whole
channel about rating just women just
friendly woman your adventures with them
have you ever heard of the channel prank
invasion
he did the same thing i was like all
right i was like
where'd you even begin with this yeah i
did yeah i didn't even want to begin
unpacking it yeah yeah yeah
what do i even do
you already got like one who would drive
is worth the time to like unpack
everything i was like uh do you even
think that like la should have like more
public transport he's like [ __ ] no man i
was like what do you think it needs he's
like we need more e-scooters
okay like it's a great idea it's
fantastic those scooters are really fun
honestly honestly i think it [ __ ]
works in cities where it has an
infrastructure of cycling because i
recently went to belgium uh and like
going like using the e-scooters in
belgium was it it was one really really
fun and two really really [ __ ]
convenient as well right right like
because we we uh me and cindy got out of
our station and we tried to like find a
taxi and like the [ __ ] line for the
taxi was like a [ __ ] mile long i
swear to god because there were just not
enough roads and not enough taxis to
accommodate everyone right so we were
looking at what everyone was doing and
everyone was either cycling or just
e-scooting so that's so nice yeah i wish
la was more like friendly to like just
like e-scooters cycling yeah yeah yeah
trains buses like in general like that
we don't have to rely on cars so much
yeah it feels like if you don't have a
car now like you're [ __ ] yeah because
wasn't there this big craze of just
people trashing e-scooters here or just
like throwing them to the river
i mean they are like i think they're
still doing it
they're probably still doing it ugly
yeah because like i get it if you leave
it on the streets just in like
the pavement or whatever right
yeah yeah yeah like in in brussels
everyone was leaving it where people
parked their bikes you know so you just
go to like a designated section
to be that considerate
[Laughter]
in san francisco they had like rental
like it's the same concept where you use
your phone to unlock but they unlocked
mopeds
and it was
yeah it was sick
we just wrote mopeds around san
francisco you don't need a license to uh
drive a moped i don't know michael did
it for me
that doesn't sound sick i don't know
like if you unlock the back they came
with two helmets because they know
people would like to write oh that's
cool that's really [ __ ] convenient
because if i had like other options that
wasn't uber and lyft that's our public
transportation yeah these days it's
really hard to get uber and lyft yeah
the prices went up and like it was hard
getting worse yeah it's really expensive
like how do you get around normal yeah
if you if you don't leave my apartment
do you drive no
can you drive
do you have a do you have a left i mean
i have a car
in japan that that would be called a car
it would be called a paper license in
japan yeah but
i don't like driving i don't like
driving either especially like
especially like driving here it seems so
stressful yeah yeah and i'm like really
panicky i think i'm doing other people a
favor by not going on the road you're
welcome
i'm saving your life everyone seems like
a really bad driver here yeah there's a
lot of road rage stuff right i just i
don't trust myself why do people just
get super [ __ ] angry and like like
immediately of like a mild inconvenience
like someone will like me because they
don't want to be here they're like
because they don't want to be here
that's the same people where you go do
you like la and they go [ __ ] no honestly
ella you just live here for like um the
people yeah yeah yeah voiceover is here
too for me but yeah if i had to pick
somewhere to live it would not be the
way honestly like i get it because i
would not want to spend any more time on
the road in la than i need to yeah like
being in la traffic here i like i i
experienced it for the first time the
other day i'm like oh this is why every
la person complains about traffic it's
like you you're a piece of your soul
just like gets lost every time you get
stuck on the highway boys it's the
season of summer the season of the sand
the sun the sea and most importantly
what is what is kimon tomashi isn't that
like the test of courage you see an
anime where the high school girls go to
a haunted place yeah absolutely right
god and yeah apparently it's supposed to
chill you down to the bone so you don't
feel as hot as you do does it work no
idea because i'm a little girl and i
don't go on those things but i can tell
you one thing that will work what that's
the sponsor for this video bloodline
bloodline the last royal vampire is a
fast-paced retro style mobile jrpg a
vampire themed card game in a modern
fantasy setting bloodline is a nice mix
of anime style cut-ins and 8-bit style
battle effects it's a classic jrpg full
of strategic and team building aspects
on top of quick stylish animated action
tons to do so you'll never get bored the
story is immersive with endless gameplay
content epic boss battles pvp battles
and over 400 characters you can summon
to create the ultimate team so what are
you waiting for go check out bloodline
the last royal vampire now link's in the
description back to the episode all
right jacqueline knows kiddos
i have some real depression in there yes
[Laughter]
it's the 10 years on twitch
it 10 years on twitch as well oh my god
yeah this this year well this month or
next month is my 10th partnered here on
twitch oh my god including like
livestream.com justin.tv
[Laughter]
yeah i could hear like a decade worth of
ptsd coming out
oh my god can you there is like 10 years
worth of like imagine being a little 19
year old lily
hi boys girl on internet the comments
you would get like when you just start
out when like it's not as common
yeah oh i need a therapy yeah
no good now i'm a well-functioning happy
healthy adult how did you i mean get
over it i guess just gotta get what are
you gonna do die at least
and then like i'll just keep going see
where it leads me
at this point it's like what other life
skills do i have you know let's be
honest he doesn't know where streamer is
what about like music full time it's
hard to make money off of music
full-time i'm learning i do make like
music yeah i upload them on streaming
services
but
it's like full time it's really hard
yeah it's super hard yeah so i think
streaming and youtubing is a good like
way to supplement what you really want
to do yeah you know all the
producer costs or like yeah um voice
acting classes or stuff like that yeah i
mean you like you dabble in a lot of
things as we've established at the
beginning so i think that's a good kind
of lifestyle yeah i think it's very good
like i think i'm super privileged like
i'm very thankful i can do this because
you know it's like everyone wants to be
a streamer or like a content creator
yeah
and i did start when there were not many
yeah i think i did get lucky in that
sense like if if you do think if you
started now with absolutely nothing you
could make it oh god hell no i mean like
they think the bar of quality now is so
much higher so much higher you spend 100
000 of every video yeah
with lighting it's insane like back then
i feel like it was so much easier
because you know more visibility less
saturation yeah but also i think you
know
when you're like let's say you come in
now now what you like your baseline of
what you expect and what you think and
how to make a video it's probably gonna
be better because everyone else is also
better i feel like back then everyone
was bad because there was no frame of
reference of what good it is yeah no one
knew what they were doing back then yeah
it's like equals three was the biggest
[ __ ] show on youtube yeah have you
tried watching equals three it sucks
[Music]
it didn't age well it is bad like and
that was that like the biggest thing on
youtube like that's weird but i remember
i used to watch that [ __ ] man yeah
i feel like the formula was there you
just removed all the commentary then now
you have like daily dose of internet
yeah which is which is basically like
compilations or just meme compilations
right you know it's i i feel like there
was something there with equals three
and then yeah but the bar always changes
right
like someone brings something or someone
adds something like you know like mr
beast has like changed how everyone
makes youtube videos yeah his style has
made it like
youtube changed over like the past two
years more than i've ever seen it yeah
like ever definitely because of this
style of now everyone talks at like 5
000 words per minute and screams but i
still have to watch it at 1.5 speed
that's that okay wow how do you watch
that 1.5 speed so my problem is i like
when i um when i want to digest
information i prefer reading i read very
fast yeah i can like read really fast
but when they're talking you hate those
please
sometimes you just need to digest the
information you know it's like i'm
getting one point five and then yes and
i have the subtitle thingy on it's that
that's what i like oh jesus i guess you
just get it you're just like
like unbuffing yourself
you're just like you know what this is
too easy i'm gonna make it hard on
myself
some people just speak too [ __ ] slow
man yeah some people those years of like
reading reddit you know paid off yeah
dude until i warned my friends if you
have chat laughs open on your phone like
glance at it i will read it like i can't
help it so please
point it away
like a [ __ ] fiend for words you're
like i could reach you
i like readings
oh my god there was one time it was
really funny i told the story all right
we're in a car scar is in the front seat
right he's in a dm
with this girl right i'm gonna make a
name um give me a name bob um barbara
okay he's in the ground with this
barbara and the reflection from his
stadium was in the car window i read
that and i'm like so who's barbara
escara and he was so shocked he's like
the reflection from the front window i
could read everything i'm like i'm just
warning you like you know
i'm scared i'm scared to pull like my
credit card out in front of you now
she just scans it in you know i'm not
interested
i think chat logs and stuff like that
are most interesting because like i i
feel like i learn a lot about people
right how you type when you think no
one's reading yeah
sorry that sounds really cool that's so
scary
i have it's like not not exactly the
same thing but uh so do you play wordle
at all wordle yeah watching someone play
wordle is actually really [ __ ]
it's actually really [ __ ]
entertaining to see how their mind works
and just like what guesses they made
like i remember we were we were in like
a like a long road trip or something and
just like joey was playing word all in
like the front seat and me and connor
were just like silently judging and
commentating in the back
words that weren't real and we all do it
yeah
everyone does it but it's funny to be
like oh you really think like flubbel
it gets to the point where you're just
like this has to be a word i don't know
you just started randomly doing it and i
hate it when people are watching me
because i'm just like don't judge me i
know this is not real no we all do it
but like it's so entertaining watching
someone else do it
it's like you [ __ ] idiots like that's
not a real word
which were though i thought the tactic
was like i have like three words i
always use yeah yeah yeah
i've stopped doing that but i realize
it's boring yeah
i just i just i just go with like my
whatever i feel like now but joey's
still on like the [ __ ] crane meta
like yeah i think the crane metal works
i i don't play wordle anymore i don't
yeah that was such a big thing everyone
on twitter was posting their little
squares yeah what is that i feel like i
missed the train i was i was very late
to it
because i was too scared to ask what the
squares were oh
you were too scared i was like is this
like some cult or something that like
people are coming in not the same way so
i would click on the replies of the
squares because people will ask and then
and then i get the answer right yeah see
i wasn't smart like once i started
playing it you could tell like there
there were some people on your feet that
that are just like you are you are
cheating i know you're [ __ ] cheating
this this word progression makes zero
[ __ ] sense and you'd see them like
they try to like mix it up sometimes
they'd get like threes and fours but
they get too many twos to be like really
to be like universally makes sense you
know i know you guys are out there i
know you gotta stop doing the world
cheetahs yeah yeah yeah
why why i can tell okay we can all tell
you social media yeah exactly
wow you're good at word all that's so
[ __ ] hot
so heading to my dms right now
dude got the two
i'm breaking up oh dude yeah that's
right come on like get it getting it too
naturally is [ __ ] like oh it's so
sexy it's so [ __ ] satisfying you know
why would you fake that that phase end
it pretty quickly i don't see this yeah
everything does online yeah yeah
yeah yeah trends online just it moves
too fast now yeah so fast is it is it's
morbid time funny still no no by the
time this is out now yeah no i know it
it's like crazy yeah yeah remember four
guys
oh people still play fall guys stuff
people do that okay
i don't think there's much of a meme as
it was though
was it even a meme before i mean there
were like there was like a period where
there were some memes you know varying
in hilarity it was like nothing compared
to among us no it came out right before
among us so yeah yeah
yeah among us
oh my gosh i mean those memes still
about my money yeah i don't even like
playing the game i just love the memes
yeah yeah
i'm almost everywhere
so you've been on youtube for ten plus
years right do you like a favorite era
of youtube when
when you like honestly i like my league
parody song days because that was that
[ __ ] was fun i'm like yeah let me
everyone was doing league paradigm i
mean i used to unironically listen to
like insta lock yeah well i know i mean
they were cute cool i thought i never
know when i go back i'm like why did i
what did i want it was like it was like
a cool era where everyone was trying to
take songs like make parodies out of it
to make it fit like league of legends
because that's fair use parody so i
would like to take like these weep songs
and like yeah um
you know it's really cringe obvious yeah
yeah but it was fun because i would draw
everything myself and do everything
myself that was creatively fulfilling
yeah for me and that was super fun for
me i like that that was a period when
people still enjoy league as well yeah
and then those remember oh god do you
guys remember league ciphers by any
chance yeah yeah they're rapping for me
it
oh my god someone invite me to one i
want to do one i know a bunch of people
who would yeah i know a bunch of people
i want to do more like anime's life is
still a thing yeah yeah please i want to
do more like anime like just like
projects if you need me to found of
anything or just like be in the project
i'm i'm desperate like why are you
desperate give me your all [ __ ] say
that pretend like you're busy yeah
it's funny because we're like
i'm desperate
every count every anime content creator
i know it's trying to get out of anime
now yeah yeah i kind of miss it's like
nostalgic i just wanted to cute silly
things again you know like whether it's
uh [ __ ] i would even do a bridge series
you know i don't [ __ ] care man
i thought you said a british series
there a british british what's going on
i'm pretty good at british accents if
you need someone to voice a british
character for you
let me just drink my bottle of water
you sound like a british person with a
concussion
like you haven't had it had a bit too
much to drink you got a bit too much
game of self trash taste in the
description
just gave up there
like you just went back to america yeah
oh my god accents um so when i audition
for stuff sometimes they want accents
right yeah my biggest like okay
when they ask for an asian accent
what does that even mean though
what does that even mean do you like the
pro cd video where he's like when they
asked me to audition with an asian
accent oh i saw that
i feel so racist like what do you want
me to do what accent do you want me to
possibly do yeah it's like an
amalgamation of like chinese creatures
so here's it i did they wanted a
japanese accent right yeah and i didn't
know how to do it so i just winged it
for my audition because i need i want
roles can i can i hear you no man i
don't know
you maybe you're american
i'm japanese all out
but the thing is i got a call back for
that role they're like yeah we really
liked it i'm like what what was i saying
and i had to re-listen to my i'm like
this is not a japanese accent
i mean
yeah
what is the accent really it's just
katakana right it's just it's just
pronouncing things in the category oh my
name is you know it's like that's like
that
what i hear from like media like other
game characters with accents i try to
emulate those yeah it's just when they
ask for like an asian accent it's always
like i'm on like put on the spot i'm
like what do you want me to do that's a
red flag
it's almost like it shouldn't be an
asian accent yeah there's a lot of
countries
right like like what if i ask you
anything is technically asian yeah like
what if i asked you to do a european
accent like what is what is a european
accent yeah well yeah even when they say
like american or british it's like well
you can there's a lot of yeah
very specific it's just like you just do
what you think is right and then if they
like it they like it if they don't like
it you know
you do a korean accent oh
i just feel so bad doing it like i i i
don't mean to make fun of anything like
yeah it's just me
really trying but i feel like people
will take it the wrong way
i've done some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
yeah
but you never know like someone [ __ ]
clips it twitter like that's true that's
true
you're a veteran
but also like aren't you korean as well
but i've done like i voiced like an
african in the game and that was not my
proudest moment but that was in a game
it's my favorite moment
everyone loves it because it's literally
like if it was before the uganda
knuckles meme
and it was literally that accident yeah
and then like but they they selected me
for some [ __ ] reason sometimes
you never know what they select you for
you know it could be the way that you
say certain things or like but it's it
was weird because when you started voice
acting right like that wasn't like a
thing yet where everyone was like you
can't do this voice if you're not uh
that right kind of yeah
ethnicity these days like they want like
yeah now you have that asian character
they want an asian people yeah it's like
they're very like because you know like
a league changed a lot of the voice
actors like very secretly yeah some of
the characters it wasn't wasn't lucian
voiced patrick yeah yeah yeah uh so
lucian and renekton were the same person
and it's a white guy patrick sites he's
done like so many he's actually i don't
know
it's really good he's amazing uh but
yeah they very quietly changed his voice
in the game
because it was weird like i mean like
obviously the when it all started
changing and uh it kind of just changed
overnight like everyone was like that's
not cool
or what yeah well i mean it's just you
know a lot of it now it's like all right
well obviously and it makes sense
obviously a black person should play a
black person right and a white person
should probably play a white person i
[ __ ] you know i don't i don't care i
just auditioned for the thing now
that's the location for it if you like
it i'm just trying to like avoid the
minefield i'm like am i good i'm good
okay i'm good i'm good
yeah yeah sometimes i'm like what it's
like something i say
online and i wake up and there's eight
thousand notifications like bully did
you see that's my night yeah i mean i
mean like that's that's like the ten
years worth of like streaming experience
to be like i need to be careful about
everything i say i'd probably sound
really like the ptsd
i think if your intent is very clear
yeah it won't i do i do try to yeah like
super like this is who i am
yeah yeah yeah thank god we cut that
stuff she said earlier
crazy
no because like luckily we're on a
podcast so like even we can like edit it
but like as a twitch streamer being
online so much
like i'm scared you know i'm scared like
i would let something slip or something
will get taken out of context yeah and
it could be totally like unintentional
or like a mistake or whatever but that
moment could like define a lot of things
yeah so you just you know just just
don't do it forehead
just get good you can't get it just be
i watched that video of him
boxing like 30 times it was so i think
the fact that there was a creator clash
with like everyone who really gave it
their all yeah there's like really good
vibes yeah yeah
wow would you guys ever box each other
like annie tuber versus
a boxing class with uh
logic the other day oh is it for the
thing yeah yeah yeah are you gonna do it
i will yeah
we'll see
how the [ __ ] gonna teach me in japan
how to box oh right you are not from
here yeah yeah i'm sure there's boxing
gyms you can go to maybe i don't know
are we recording by the way yeah we are
oh okay
are you going to box dude i'm too
self-conscious when they s well you look
like [ __ ] when you box because you you
[ __ ] you're sweating you're getting
yeah no one looks like a model when they
box yeah some of the people look kind of
cool like their forms and stuff like the
whole dodging weaving like i thought
that was really cool but they also
slathered your face with like vaseline
before yeah you know their faces were
really shiny yeah different cuts and
stuff yeah i didn't know that yeah
was it like watching michael live during
croatia i was screaming i was so excited
and happy i was like yeah that's it i
was like in discord with like six other
friends watching the same thing and
we're just like screaming for it was
energy was great yeah
was it nerve-wracking because like
i mean you're watching you're watching
your part in a box so i'd be [ __ ]
scared i'm scared he was gonna get like
hit in the head and then what if he just
gets a concussion and dies or something
i don't know there's a real fear of that
head injuries are terrible yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you can literally like get
brain damage yeah so i was scared of
that but then as soon as i saw his form
and stuff i'm like yeah he knows he's
good yeah yeah he knows he's really good
yeah especially like out of a lot of
people he just seemed like he took to it
so naturally yeah
the person where if he wants to learn
something he will learn it yeah
so i was very impressed but you were
going to talk about that with him yeah
we'll talk about it with him as well
yeah yeah
wait is this like separate is this is am
i coming out first and then yeah yeah
you'll kill me i'm sorry am i spoiling
to guess yes you could spoil it
so spoilers michael reed's next yeah
you guys should definitely talk to him
about anime and british food
i'm excited because i'm gonna be
like not the british so yeah it's
i know one of the shows he loves so i'm
excited to talk to him about that yeah
he loves what he loves banana fish
oh i thought about arcane
i was like
can we talk to him about arcane he loves
our kids less [ __ ]
yeah it's so funny where i'm just going
priviling yourself of one of the
greatest tv shows out of all time out of
spite
ex what can i say i'm a cancer
okay all right yeah
well guys thank you so much for watching
the trash taste podcast episode number
one
okay it's probably 106 probably not
because with episode number 106. insert
107
108. use one of those
if you like this make sure you check out
the description for these uh gamer sub
bottles
cold trash taste for 10 off i don't know
is it 10
it's probably something like something
like that yeah like you know what you
want to shout out our patreons as well
patreon patreon yeah yeah yeah look at
all these names yeah look at all these
names look at all these names that are
on screen right now
contributing wow
[Applause]
hey guys welcome to the offline tv
podcast
yeah well thank you so much make sure
hit a subscribe give us a comment what
was your favorite topic in today's
podcast who do you want to see next
should joey watch our games
oh yeah so many questions
uh of course uh as well check out lily's
stuff uh links in the description below
check out lily peacho on spotify and get
me those stream plays yeah
get that extra 0.01 cents not even more
not even 3.00
that's ridiculous but uh hey if you like
support the show go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the sub reddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify but uh yeah thanks for coming
that was really professional thank you
yeah thank you thank you that's why we
leave the outros to him yeah that's
right
i'll try to touch it yeah i don't even
know what he said yeah if he's not here
i'm just like i don't know
how do we end this show
[Music]
you